probably what I've got here I think
these are the easy bits you're like okay
I'm saying to get a pattern I'm ignoring
this part down the bottom over here
because I know I'm not allowed to take
the square root of a negative number in
fact we haven't written it before but
I'd love you to write it now when you
highlight that part the reason you're
highlighting it is because the square
root of this part is undefined
so that's why I'm not drawing anything
over there okay so go ahead write that
next to your highlighting and then
you've got these are values that ended
up being useful right I've got the zero
over there on the left and I drew a fat
blob there because I know my graphs
going to start there you've got these
one two three points where the graph is
exactly equal to one and then I also
went ahead and did four because I know
the square root of four is it's two
right now that's pretty nice I'm
reasonably confident that because I've
been graphing these for ages I would
know exactly where this goes but maybe
if you're like not a hundred percent you
can put a couple of extra points on for
instance I keep on looking for a
particular fraction what is it I well I
will look at zero point six in a second
but the main one I'm looking for is a
quarter I keep looking for a quarter
because I know what the square root of a
quarter is right just like I know the
square root of four is two the square
root of 1/4 is 1/2 this over there that
is where I say a quarter right the
square root of that is going to be 1/2
just above now serene mentioned point
six I see point six right there what's
the square root of point six actually
don't know content times produce zero
point seven seven so that's a bit higher
like that okay yeah just a bit higher
like point six and then point seven
seven yeah so you could do it at this
one you can now do as many poison you
like but I'm pretty confident I know
what this is going to do I'm going to
draw a shape like this actually I'm
gonna draw it another color just so it's
really obvious where you can you guys
see this green so coming out yep it's
gonna weave up and down it's going to go
right through there and then over here I
think
that should do it what do you think yeah
so this is the shape that I'm getting I
should do this say that again
now by the way this guy over here maybe
I should have drawn it so it goes a
little bit steeper because unlike this
is quite hard to do there that's a bit
better unlike in the previous example
you know how we're like oh look it
starts to become a straight line right
see this guy here why don't we start
with the original function why does it
look like a cubic right so it's a it's a
I can actually tell you it's a wake up y
equals x cubed minus X plus one I'm only
telling you that so you can put into des
Vosges if you like when you take the
square root of this thing right just
look at that first term the square root
of x cubed what power what index goes
with the square root like how could I
write the square root 16 in index
notation it's 16 ^ does anyone know yeah
whatever to 1/2 so the square root of x
cubed is X to the power of 3 over 2 now
I'll let you go and explore that desmos
yourself X to the power of 3 over 2 is
not a straight line X to the power of 1
is a straight line and this is a bit
different does grow just slower okay all
right last one I'm so confident I reckon
we can do this one together we can do
all the nice easy spots I'm not even
going to draw the y equals 1 line
because I think you can spot it pretty
well let's look for where y equals 1 can
you see the two spots they're kind of
there on the side over here there's y
equals 1 there's y equals 1 right where
am I getting 0 what X values minus 2 and
2 so I'm going to draw a nice fat blob
there what other point might be
important to me can you select one for
me
X is 2 or Y is 2 y is 2 I've got the top
of the circle like was 2 and that's
gonna be about 1.4 right so I'm putting
that I'd say it's about there okay and
you can put in as many points as you
like now but you're going to get this
kind of weird sort of would like that
same but different that one wasn't very
good under - try it again what TV show
same but different okay
now we're about to do something can you
turn back to the first page you're
looking at we're about to do something
which sounds like it's gonna be a whole
new thing but it's actually just a
continuation of what we're about to do
okay no you're gonna do this as well
okay but importantly if you have another
color for this they'll be really really
useful okay what we're about to do now
is not like was the square root of the
function it's can you write this on the
side please y squared equals the
function now that sounds like it's a
whole new thing you like all the
goodness how do I deal with this okay
it's not a whole new thing can I ask you
this question
eyes up for a second if I all see us you
solve this equation a squared equals 49
what would your next line be a equals
plus or minus they both work right they
both work what you did was you took the
square root but you also said there's
two ways to do this right positive one
negative one well now I want you to
think about how that applies to what
we're looking at here if I went why
what's the next line plus or minus what
it's the square root right you went from
49 to seven you took the square root
right this is a square root of right now
you already know what the plus square
root of x looks like it's right there
now think back to yesterday morning we
did reflections right
what is minus of this it's flipped
across the x axis its underneath so can
you go ahead and do your very best and
draw the same thing but draw it upside
down it's gonna go down like that all
right
that's a parabola it's the whole thing
which shouldn't surprise you because
it's a y squared
this is y squared equals X minus 2
it's a parabola it's just the other way
around right what about this guy
what's it gonna look like same thing
yeah it's two they're not quite
parabolas but it's the same idea it's
gonna be about there let's try a bonus
that's right it's the whole thing not
only the top but also the bottom thank
you that is complete right it is the
whole graph the pup the blue part and
the purple part that is the Y squared
equals f of X right cuz you got the top
part it's positive you got the bottom
part it's negative what's gonna happen
here
this guy's gonna look weird think about
this carefully
it's my green graph right I'm gonna do
my very best to do the same thing but
upside down about there okay wish me
luck people think I'm gonna get
something like this
they're just gonna go down it's gonna go
up it's gonna go like that what is that
what is that thing yeah it's sort of
like a weird rollercoaster where at some
point you go upside down okay they go
right now this guy's weird right is this
a function this new thing this is not a
function what do we call it starts with
an R it's a relation thank you it fails
the vertical line test but just because
the vertical line test doesn't mean you
can't draw it it's really cool thing the
entire thing green and purple and last
one down here what is it it's the same
thing flipped over yeah this guy it's
sort of like a yeah like a fat looking
like someone sat on an oval right yeah
that's right it's like what sorry I
gained some weight and a bit fat on the
ends okay
so when you take the whole thing blue
and purple you're getting Y squared
equals f of X
it's the top part it's the top hey guys
one last quick note in Rastan hopefully
this answers your question but ask if it
doesn't right what we've been
considering is the difference between
I'm gonna go to your page the difference
between y equals the square root of f of
X compared to Y squared equals f of X
right essentially you're getting the top
half or you're getting the whole thing
and actually you've known this for a
while think back to one equation you've
only learnt one equation and how to
graph it before today you've only
learned one equation where hash which
had a y squared in it do you remember
which one it was
there's an equation that had a y squared
in it was the circle right do you
remember this guy this is a circle this
is the unit circle right I could
rearrange it like this that is still the
unit circle right that's the unit circle
but this guy over here I'll do it in
another color this guy over here is not
a circle anymore what is it it's a
semicircle is just the top half what
would I do if I wanted the bottom half
I'd slap a minus sign that's the bottom
half right so you can see this is just
the top half right and this is the whole
thing right y squared gives you the
mirror image on both sides the square
root only gives you the blue part blue
part their green part they're sorry
blue and their blue okay